there is said to be growing debate
tonight within the top levels of the
biden administration
about whether to recommend or mandate
the use of masks
to deal with the resurgence of the
coronavirus and the delta variant
white house correspondent peter ducey
tells us where things stand tonight
masks for the vaccinated maybe as
president biden waits for the latest
from advisors
i think he's of course looking for
their updates and guidance on what the
spread is major policy changes could be
a ways off
the general cdc guidelines are still
whole
that you do not need to wear a mask
indoors if in fact
you've been vaccinated for the first
time since late last year the seven-day
average of vaccine doses going into arms
is below 300 000 a day as variants
spread do you know if there's been any
talk here
about updating guidance to start
shutting businesses down
in places that have very low vaccination
rates no there has not been no
in new york mayor bill de blasio is
asking all employers in the city to
require vaccinations
in saint louis masks are now required
indoors even for the vaccinated
and masks are quickly becoming a midterm
election issue
if i'm elected governor here in arkansas
we will not have mass mandates
other republicans say they worry about
who gets final say
nobody elected the cdc no one elected
tony fauci to make these decisions
advisors advise elected officials decide
the delta variant is not
affecting president biden's travel
schedule yet
nothing has changed about our approach
or protocols over the past week
and that includes a lack of transparency
about infected staffers because
despite this promise from the president
i will always level with you
use franklin roosevelt's example i'll
shoot to get his straight from the
shoulder
straight from the shoulder what i know
and what i don't know
his administration won't detail positive
cases
do you have a account or can you offer
any confirmation to us on the percentage
of employees who are vaccinated i'm not
going to provide that are you trying to
hide something
no but what is the why do you need to
have that information transparency
while businesses and schools and summer
camps wait to hear
from the government whether or not
they're supposed to start masking up
again the president isn't saying much
about this
no public events on the schedule today
nothing until tonight when he
motorcades over to virginia for a
political
rally on behalf of a democratic
candidate for governor there his first
rally like this as president and the
first for him of the coming
election cycle right peter ducey live on
the north lawn peter thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else